si c'est la queue blanche comme neige que vous
recherchez découvrez l'histoire qui a
précédé j'étais vraiment excité juste parce que
je sentais qu'il y avait plus à explorer depuis
le premier film Freya et Ravenna sont des
sœurs tu m'as toujours laissé te gagner tout mon
pouvoir de faiblesse  car Ravenne est tout
pour elle c'est l'air qu'elle respire
qui est la plus belle de toutes tu es
ma reine
mais pas pour longtemps ta soeur tient un
bébé qui deviendra plus beau
que toi
Ravenne a des pouvoirs extraordinaires Freya
n'a pas encore découvert  la sienne et la tragédie
se produit elle libère ce pouvoir incroyable
en elle
et Freya
veut finalement sauver son royaume mais Ravenne
veut tout contrôler
il ne peut y avoir qu'une seule reine c'est mon
royaume tu vois la rivalité fraternelle
revenir en entier  force as-tu dit quelque chose
petite soeur Freya se défend
et dit pas plus je suis plus fort
que toi nous le découvrirons et les
deux ils vont à la guerre préparent le
Chasseur pour la guerre deux des êtres les plus
puissants de cet univers et  maintenant en
tête-à-tête notre histoire Cass
[Music]
c'est tout un tour